[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de tv5monde face aux territoires
une émission coproduite vous le savez
avec ouest-france qui nous diffuse
d'ailleurs en live en direct sur ouest
france.fr avec le groupe nice-matin
également qui est regardable sur
nicematin.com et puis france antilles
france antilles point fr qui nous
diffuse aussi en léger différé dû au
décalage horaire aux fuseaux horaires
différents bien sûr aux antilles mon
invité ce matin c'est gérard larcher
bonjour bonjour monsieur le président du
sénat vous êtes également diffusée ce
matin partie des 78 la chaîne les
yvelines au département qui représenté
par thierry barbedette qui était présent
sur ce plateau votre département nous
allons aborder évidemment avec vous des
questions politiques des questions de
territoire et puis aussi des questions
internationales puisque vous êtes le 2e
ou 3e personnage de l'état ya toujours
une petite eu ce type de situation vous
êtes le deuxième tour nous sommes en
colère voilà enfin c'est le deuxième
pour nous ce matin voilà président
larcher la cinquième vague est dans tous
les esprits des français sont
extrêmement inquiet notamment des de la
parole gouvernementale ces derniers
jours valérie pécresse et xavier
bertrand veut se sont prononcés lors du
débat pour 1 re confinement des non
vaccinés quelle est votre position
est-ce possible aussi techniquement
législativement parlant d'abord
face à la montée d'une nouvelle vague
forte en europe de l'est
assez forte en europe du nord
aujourd'hui la france est et les pays ou
s'il semble un peu plus préservés la
seule réponse les vaccinale et c'est une
position que le sénat très
majoritairement adopté et la troisième
injection quand le moment est venu doit
être fait et il faudra naturellement
qu'on l'ait tendent au delà des règles
des 65 ans des des comorbidités
naturellement pour les enfants il faut
attendre l'avis des des autorités de
santé mais c'est important et je le
rappelle parce que c'est aussi ma
responsabilité le respect de gestes
barrières nous les avions un public on a
tellement envie de se retrouver regardez
comme les maires ont été heureux de se
retrouver cette semaine au congrès des
maires qui à ce besoin là mais il faut
qu'on se conjugue avec la chanter alors
sur votre question
il faut c'est faisable rapidement est-ce
que c'est faisable rapidement si le
gouvernement et est amené à prendre la
décision
de décréter un nouvel état d'urgence de
l'état d'urgence serait différent
puisque il pourrait être un état
d'urgence qui concerne uniquement les
non vaccinés on passerait de l'état
d'urgence territoriales à l'ugta
d'urgence personnels et pour les
individus et bien sûr et bien sûr avec
le risque de discrimination ça n'est pas
plus facile alors il faut pas ça dans le
délai d'un mois de passer devant le
parlement et d'ailleurs le parlement
n'est que suspendu après le dernier jour
de février au conseil constitutionnel
également français et yonnel ce n'est
pas une obligation mais il est fort
probable qu'à certains de collègues
demanderai l'avis du conseil constitue
un tour la question proportionnalité
santé liberté est une des
responsabilités du sénat s'est dit
extrêmement attentive aux libertés
individuelles et collectives mais aussi
bien sur l'aspect santé de nos
concitoyens dit ce matin c'est que ce
n'est pas une procédure simple il faut
passer par la maison doit être nous
l'avons toujours dit c'est une position
constante du sénat vous rendez compte
quand on va être le 31 juillet sa frappe
27 mois qu'on est en état d'urgence
jamais notre pays n'aura connu ça ça
n'est possible que sous le contrôle du
parlement david lisnard le président de
la mf le nouveau président de la msa a
été hier soir l'association des maires
de france est ce que vous n'avez pas là
au fond un nouveau problème est-ce que
c'est pas un nouveau prétendant au
leadership de la droite on a vu tout de
suite les commentaires derrière cette
élection disant ça y est il y en a un
nouveau qui arrive ça vous inquiète
passagers rien président des maires qui
va poursuivre ceux qui avaient été
conduits par françois baroin par jacques
pélissard c'est à dire avoir une
association des maires qui est
pluraliste
et qui est aussi indépendante de tous
les gouvernements mais son président est
de verser à ses résidents il a une
légitimité forte y compris parce qu'on a
décrit une concurrence que un certain
temps se sont engagés
derrière les candidats c'est pas nouveau
problème pour la droite d'avoir un
nouveau leader est une formidable chance
pas simplement pour la droite mais pour
les maires de france d'avoir un
président légitime d'ailleurs très
largement élu avec une participation
assez exceptionnel c'est je crois une
force c'est la force des 35000 commune
et c'est la force de territoire unis
demain avec les départements les régions
voilà c'est le président du sénat gérard
larcher qui est notre invité ce matin
sur tv5monde vous savez gérard larcher
dans 200 pays et en 14 langues vous êtes
regarder dans un instant françois-xavier
le franc le rédacteur en chef de ouest
france nous rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier maufront bonjour
bonjour rédacteur en chef de ouest
france le premier quotidien francophone
du monde et julie baup parle beaucoup
moi oui oui vous c'est l'édition horn
oui mes racines vous êtes né dans leur
vie je suis né dans l'orne et j'ai
beaucoup d'attachés dans cette normandie
qui m'a vu grandir beaucoup transmis
dans un instant nous allons parler des
questions de territoire avec vous
françois xavier le franc mais tout de
suite richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui était notre
invité le 7 octobre dernier
a parlé sur ce plateau ça nous avait
d'ailleurs tous étonnés à propos du
cumul des mandats en écoute richard
ferrand et on prend la réaction de
gérard larcher derrière moi justement
rien interroge tous ceux qui seraient de
nature à rendre les choses plus claires
et précisément à faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de dichotomie entre les élus
locaux si je puis dire et les élus
nationaux donc que l'on réinterroge cela
fait partie des chantiers ouvrir ne me
faites pas dire que soudain je dis il
faut rétablir les cumuls jeudi il faut
vous avez des quartiers voilà il faut
s'interroger pourquoi on accepterait le
cumul de mandats locaux et quand on
interdirait l'exercice au titre des
internationaux gérard larcher je voyais
sourire en même temps acquiescé oui à
quai c'est parce que c'est une position
constante d'une large majorité au sénat
est important de parler de mes racines
ornaise eh bien le mandat local à la
fois nous donne une légitimité
l'expérience et il est tout à fait
possible de conjuguer l'exercice d'un
mandat local dans l'exercice de
plusieurs fonctions dont vous un mandat
local d'un mandat exécutif local
d'ailleurs le sénat
l'avait à l'époque votée à l'initiative
damman aujourd'hui du conseil
constitutionnel jacques mézard radical
de gauche et vient de leur jeter à
l'initiative du président du groupe de
l'union centriste hervé marseille vous
souhaiteriez qu'on puisse être maire et
sénateur et ou d'exercer des fonctions
exécutives départementales voire
régionales
alors il faudrait cadres et bien sûr
cela nous avions dit s'agit pas de
retrouver la multiplicité des fonctions
mais on se nourrit on se nourrit du
local cette expérience là elle est tout
à fait essentiel justement les maires
les maires qui élisent les sénateurs il
faut le rappeler les sénateurs sont élus
par les grands électeurs les maires vous
les connaissez particulièrement bien et
les maires vous le savez qu'on une
inquiétude qui n'est pas nouvelle autour
des services publics de l'organisation
des services publics sur les territoires
avec souvent notamment dans le monde
rural que vous connaissez vous l'avez
dit parfois un sentiment d'inégalité
alors comment garantir au maire quand on
les voit quand on les rencontre vous
avez rencontrées vous n'avez vu
plusieurs milliers là ces jours ci
comment leur garantir une présence
réelle des services publics sur les
territoires et en même temps au moment
d'une campagne présidentielle annoncé la
suppression de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de fonctionnaires puisque c'est
ce que les candidats aient l'air ont
annoncé en tout cas pour valérie
pécresse xavier bertrand
je crois que la réponse n est pas
simplement dans cette espèce e du
système binaire il faudrait plus de
fonctionnaires pour plus de service
public il faut d'abord revoir j'allais
dire les relations entre l'état les
services de l'état et l'organisation
territoriale voilà pourquoi il nous faut
une nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation
il nous faut de la subsidiarité faire
confiance à la proximité à voir
aujourd'hui par exemple un système
organisationnel qui a prévu des doublons
partout je vais prendre la gestion d'un
sujet très sensible pendant la pandémie
est aujourd'hui la gestion par exemple
du médico-social de la protection de la
jeunesse de l'accueil de nos aînés dans
les ehpad on a des doubles des triple
tutelle etc donc c'est réorganisation
profonde qui nous devons conduire ça
s'appelle la décentralisation ça
s'appelle la déconcentration de l'état
ça veut dire que il faut pas faire du
couple préfet maire uniquement j'allais
dire le refrain d'un psaume mais le
maître concrètement s'il veut dire aussi
renforcé mais en même temps locale en
même temps parfois on supprime les
fonctionnaires et on utilise
en dématérialisant comme on dit c'est à
dire qu'on remplace des fonctionnaires
par des boîtes vocales
et là aussi ça exclut ou alors par on
demande aux gens d'aller sur un an elle
quand elle avait la facture numérique
elle existe
on a montré qu'on remplacés par des
boîtes vocales des fonctionnaires qu'on
ne supprimez pas mon objectif c'est pas
de supprimer des fonctionnaires c'est de
retrouver de la proximité il faut qu'on
fasse très attention
nous avons près d'un tiers de nos
compatriotes qui ont des difficultés
dans la relation avec le dématérialisé
avec le numérique
et nous devons être extrêmement attentif
à ne pas amplifier cette fracture qui
n'est pas que rural qui est aussi
urbaine et donc à un moment ce pays est
tellement fracturée on doit être
président gérard larcher s'est présentée
senna qui est notre invité ce matin vous
êtes connu pour une formule les élus
locaux le maire est apportée
d'engueulades la responsabilité des
maires elle est très importante mais il
faut y croire pour être mère il faut y
croire pour être maire ce qu'on s'occupe
de plein de choses et il ya des risques
notamment des risques de se retrouver
devant la justice pour des actions qu'on
a parfois pas forcément vu ou maîtrisés
il ya un réel risque et beaucoup de
maires d'ailleurs ce en pleine qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire aujourd'hui pour
pour améliorer ça c'est bien dans un
texte qui va être examiné aujourd'hui au
sénat nous abordons un sujet qui est par
exemple le sujet devant lesquels lé
maire sont parfois confrontés je pense à
des maires de communes qui sont pas très
importantes en nombre d'habitants qui
sont mises devant des responsabilités de
conflit d'intérêts tout simplement parce
que dans leur conseil municipal
il ya un conseiller municipal qui ne
s'est pas abstenu ou n'y a pas pensé au
moment du vote de la subvention clubs
sportifs ou à l'association
cycliste ou d'un jeu de cartes je dis ça
parce que aujourd'hui nous allons
reconnaître que quand le délit n'est pas
intentionnel eh bien on protège le maire
il y avait déjà eu la loi fauchon et à
quelques années pour protéger les mères
il ya aussi la protection du maire
apportez d'engueulades parce que
maintenant parce qu'il est apportée
d'engueulades il est dans la proximité
et à faut pas se tromper seuls les
maires les maires adjoints et
conseillers municipaux ou encore la
confiance une crise des vocations ainsi
grâce et une crise des vocations j'ai
pas si sûr qui a écrit des vocations ils
ont besoin d'être soutenus d'être
accompagné je viens d voire très
nombreux j'ai participé à une table
ronde avant-hier au four il continue à y
croire ils ont été exceptionnels le
président du rdr aura placé ces derniers
temps que le rôle social du maire n'a
jamais été aussi important oui il a
raison et pas simplement dans des
communes de petite taille ou ou de
taille moyenne y compris dans des
grandes villes et il est l'interlocuteur
celui qui peut apaiser celui qui peut
donner aussi de l'espérance il ya eu la
crise sanitaire ce niveau du rôle des
maires dans la crise et gilet jaune et
puisque nous venons d'avoir fait mémoire
du drame du bataclan j'ai un souvenir
précis comme président du sénat quand
les citoyens se poser la question qu'est
ce qui se passait dans ce pays avec ces
attentats terroristes
c'est au tour des maires qu'ils se sont
retrouvés le maire c'est quelque part a
simplement un refuge c'est aussi une
référence alors exhorté les citoyens
comprennent l'action du maire
connaissent leur mère ils étaient
effectivement apporté d'engueulades il
ya quelque chose que le citoyen
perçoivent beaucoup moins c'est l'action
des régions l'action des départements
l'action de tous ces niveaux de décision
de millefeuille le millefeuille on a vu
lors des dernières élections on n'arrête
pas de le répéter mais lors des
dernières élections les taux de
participation quand même très faible est
l'une des raisons c'est que les gens
disaient on n'y comprend rien on n'y
comprend rien à la façon dont on vote
pour les régionales pour les
départementales comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait simplifier ça parce que
l'impression qu'il ya que les hommes
politiques et les journalistes qui
suivent ça qu'ils comprennent quelque
chose donc comment comment on peut
rendre sa lisible d'abord sur la
participation aux dernières élections
ce n'a pas commencé il y avait bien sûr
la pandémie mais depuis dix ans nous
assistons une forme de détournement
d'une partie de nos compatriotes de
l'expression démocratique
je crois que ça traduit plus une rice du
résultat il ya tellement eu d'engagement
prix qui n'ont pas été suivis j'allais
dire des faits que les gens disent je
vote mais à quoi ça sert par contre
mieux connaître le rôle des régions
mieux connaître le rôle des départements
c'est le travail pour engager notamment
ensemble les trois grandes associations
d'élus au travers de territoire unis on
a vu dans la crise dans la crise
sanitaire le rôle complémentaire et non
pas concurrents de la région du
département et de la commune quand il
s'est agi de faire face par exemple à la
crise des masques d'ouvrir des centres
de vaccination de gérer la question
scolaire on va aller ensemble on va
parler au moment pendant la campagne
présidentielle on va parler forcément de
décentralisation ce serait quoi la
mesure immédiate à prendre une mesure
qui pourrait avoir un effet rapide et
qui permettrait de faciliter les choses
pour les pour les élus locaux qui
souvent ont l'impression que l'état ne
leur fais pas confiance qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour débloquer il ya
d'abord un texte en cas de discussion
très concrètement que les députés vont
examiner qui s'appelle la loi 3ds qui
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
décentralisation déconcentration
différenciation et bien les députés pour
l'examen examiner les semaines du 6 et
du 13 décembre mais j'espère qu'on va
avancer mais ça ne suffira pas ça ne
suffira pas parce que je crois que le
premier sujet c'est de retrouver la
confiance dans les relations entre
l'état central et des territoires nous
vivons la verticalité nous vivons la
recentralisation et la vraie mesure mais
s'il se creusera de retrouver ses yeux
comme la république ça non c'est pas
vieux comme la république parce que
pardonnez-moi de gaston defferre à
jacques chirac on a construit une vraie
décentralisation
je suis il fallait deux cette vague des
élus est le vrai sujet ce sera de
retrouver pour les collectivités
territoriales une part d'autonomie
financière et fiscale sur lequel y aura
pas de vraie décentralisation gérard
larcher le président du sénat est notre
invité ce matin gérard larcher une
tradition dans cette émission le
dessinateur et italie ouest-france qui
s'appelle chaunu à une question vous
poser sous forme de dessin qu'on vous
donnera on le regarde
à 1,10 pensable sénat à la vie
démocratique de notre pays fonctionne
comme un véritable contre-pouvoir bon
c'est vrai que les français ont parfois
du mal à comprendre son utilité alors ne
faudrait-il pas le faire évoluer un peu
comme le bundesrat allemand c'est-à-dire
un véritable parlement des territoires
bon président on connaît votre flair
légendaire flers votre ville natale en
normandie et c'est vrai que du perchoir
vous avez une vue imprenable sur
l'ensemble du pays alors ma question
peut vous paraître un peu primaire mais
entre les alpes les hauts de france
la côte d'azur ou l'île de france vers
qui va votre préférence
voilà j'ai pas de préférence j'aime la
france comme un puzzle de 35000 commune
qui prend la forme d'un hexagone et vous
lui avez pas évoquer nos outre mer qui
sont une nouvelle version 3 océans on
n'a pas bien pour moi et est aussi
essentiel et donc c'est cette france là
que j'aime et c'est une france qui a une
capacité en 70 fracture de nous
rassembler moi je ne suis pas de ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut plus fracturée le
pays y compris quand on a des sujets
aussi
difficile à traiter que la question
migratoire ou que la question de notre
identité il faut d'abord rassembler à
une ouest france françois xavier le
front aujourd'hui alors là une de ouest
france et bien c'est la cinquième vague
de kobe qui pose effectivement beaucoup
de questions mais c'est aussi la
question opposés au président de la
république et il le président des
territoires sera-t-il le président des
territoires en tout cas les maires l'ont
dit et l'ont répété cette dernière heure
ils attendent beaucoup oui et les
attendent beaucoup cet après midi et je
crois que le scrutin d'hier a été
révélateur d'une volonté des territoires
de ne pas être les agents de l'état de
ne pas être en quelque sorte les
supplétifs de l'exécutif mais de
travailler avec l'exécutif
et donc de retrouver les chemins de la
confiance et quel que soit demain le
président ou la présidente de la
république vous savez des territoires
ils attendent le retour de la confiance
qu'on leur fasse confiance parce qu'il
existe une intelligence territoriale
regardez dans vos territoires de ouest
france la diversité des territoires
diversité l'autre jour en vendée il ya
une intelligence territoriale que je
ressens aussi dont ces territoires de ce
grand ouest comme dans le reste du pays
bon dans un instant denis carot nous
rejoint sur ce plateau merci françois
xavier le franc rédacteur en chef de
ouest france le plus grand quotidien
français merci
[Musique]
denis carot nous allons avant d'aborder
les questions à peu régaliennes avec
vous et politiques aller du côté de
grignon dans les yvelines vous
connaissez bien gérard larcher c'était
la référence en matière d'agronomie en
france à grignan l'état a vendu il y a
trois mois et demi un grand groupe mais
la procédure a été arrêté vous faisiez
partie des opposants on écoute ville
friederici de tv 78 de la chaîne des
yvelines sur ce sujet
gérard larcher bonjour l'actualité cette
semaine dans votre département les
yvelines a été marquée par l'abandon de
la vente par l'état un promoteur privé
du domaine de grignon un site est situé
dans une petite commune mais qui
représente tout de même 2 190 ha de
patrimoine naturel et architectural
puisque depuis 1826 on y forment l'élite
des agronomes français il sera bientôt
abandonnée par l'école agroparistech qui
va déménager à dès l'an prochain sur le
plateau de saclay dans l'essonne c'est
en août que la vente au groupe altarea
cogedim avait été annoncé depuis la
mobilisation n'a eu cesse de grossir
jusqu'à l'annulation donc de cette vente
vous faisiez partie des opposants aux
côtés des élus locaux de tous bords des
étudiants des chercheurs comme le nobel
le climatologue jean jouzel et l'idée de
créer à la place un centre international
dédié à l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement a été évoquée est ce que
c'est une idée que vous soutenez et puis
plus largement j'aimerais avoir votre
regard sur la gestion de ce dossier par
l'état j'ai sur ce dossier illustre la
méthode verticale on décide d'en haut
sans lien avec les élus du territoire
s'en vient d'abord avec le maire de la
commune sans lien avec
l'intercommunalité qui l a proposé de
s'engager dans la reprise de ce domaine
pour y construire ensemble co-construire
partagées avec l'état eh bien non à
bercy on a préféré en quelque sorte de
l'argent sonnant et trébuchant au
travers de la vente directe d'un grand
groupe fort heureusement la décision et
la sagesse sont revenus après la
mobilisation de tous les élus les
étudiants les chercheurs et ceux qui
avaient été formés dans cette école des
yvelines aux antilles c'est ça la france
des territoires cyril bouttier qu'il est
directeur éditorial du groupe france
antilles à une question à vous poser
gérard larcher elles concernent dans vos
prédécesseurs on écoute bonjour gérard
larcher dans une lettre ouverte publiée
dans les colonnes de nos journaux une
quarantaine de personnes issues
notamment du parti radical
demande la panthéonisation de gaston
monnerville l'un de vos illustres
prédécesseurs à la tête du sénat seriez
vous prêt à appuyer cette demande et
plus largement comment pensez vous qu'il
est possible
d'avoir une meilleure représentation des
personnes issues des outre-mer
dans la politique mémorielle si les
gamins france j'ai soutenu
et donc je n'ai plus à le faire parce
que c'est une décision que nous avons
porté notamment à l'initiative du vice
président du sénat georges patient nous
avons connu une journée de lundi dans le
cadre du congrès des maires qui s'est
déroulé lundi après midi au sénat avec
les élus d outre mer il y a tout un
symbole
gaston monnerville
quelqu'un qui combat tulle le rachis ce
qui a combattu le nazisme qui a été un
résistant qui était un homme d'état il
n'a pu avoir des dissensions c'est le
gaulliste qui le dit avec le général de
gaulle mais il avait un sens profond un
sens profond de l'état très attaché au
bicamérisme et je dois dire que occupant
à titre temporaire le bureau qu'il a
occupées quelque part cet esprit gaston
monnerville j'ai essayé de le partager
puisqu'on parlait état d'urgence j'ai
retrouvé le dialogue qu'il avait eu avec
du général de gaulle que tu ta dialogue
positif sur la question de l'état
d'urgence
gérard larcher on va parler
environnement la côte 26 s'est terminé
ce week-end le 2 novembre le sénat avait
pris une résolution demandant un accord
ambitieux le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'on en est loin oui on n'est pas
tout à fait à l'accord que nous
espérions dans la résolution du 2
novembre
néanmoins nous avons progressé sur un
poids à la coop des parlementaires à
l'union interparlementaire nous avons
déposé un amendement qui a été adoptée
qui provient du du sénat français c'est
le rôle et la place des collectivités
territoriales dans toutes les politiques
j'allais dire de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique alors il ya des
choses positives moi j'essaie toujours
de regarder les deux aspects on voit
qu'à la volonté de s'engager de 200 pays
on voit qu'aujourd'hui on a un cadre de
référence alors qu'on était dans la
déclaration à la coop de paris ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est trois choses
c'est à dire une vraie détermination sur
la fin des gilles fossiles en 2050
deuxième aspect des choses l'absence de
soutien clairement marqué aux pays du
sud je pense aux 100 milliards dont ils
ont besoin je pense notamment à la
barrière verte au travers de l'afrique
et puis il faut le dire les risques les
dégâts irrémédiables on ne les a pas
encore reconnu mais on aura une coop
l'an prochain en egypte ça va être
l'occasion pour les pays d'afrique de
s'exprimer et puis la prochaine copa
prix aura lieu aux émirats arabes unis
parce que je suis quelqu'un qui croit
qu'il y a un avenir possible et qu'on
doit gérer je sors quand même qu'on a
progressé
d'ici là il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont être faites et on le voit il ya
énormément de mer qui dansent des
programmes de transition écologique
ambitieux est ce que dans le fond c'est
pas eux qui ont le pouvoir de faire
changer les choses c'est pour ça que
nous avons souhaité cet abondement
serene carreau nous avons souhaité cet
amendement parce que sans les
collectivités territoriales mais dans le
monde entier
nous le voyons aussi dans ce qu'on
appelle la coopération décentralisée des
projets qui porteraient sur les
questions des matières entre des régions
de france et des régions d'afrique entre
des villes de france et et des villes
d'afrique ou du moyen-orient c'est une
manière à la fois de conduire des
actions mais aussi une pédagogie proche
des citoyens dans la proximité ça nous
renvoie au maire de tout à l'heure à la
réalité de la proximité de la
subsidiarité emmanuel macron a annoncé
le lancement d'un nouveau programme
nucléaire après avoir annoncé des
fermetures de centrales est ce que ce
changement de cap est une bonne nouvelle
c'est vrai que le cas pas varié depuis
la fermeture de fessenheim jusqu'à
l'annoncent d'au moins 6 p r nouveau
c'est encore un peu un peu flou et
l'abandon d'astrid entre deux en 2019
qui était une manière d'avancer aussi
sur une question qui reste pendante
qu'est la question des déchets
nucléaires et sur laquelle l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques est en train actuellement
de travailler parce que et le sénat
toujours une position équilibrée 2015
comme madame ségolène royal nous fait un
texte de transition énergétique nous
réaffirmons que seul le mix énergétique
est une réponse qui ne faut pas fixer un
calendrier de fermeture du nucléaire qui
avait pourtant repris le président
macron début de ce mandat le mix
énergétique j'étais en ciel l'économie
d'énergie est essentiel et demain si
nous voulons ne plus avoir des énergies
d'origine fossile nous savons c'est le
rapport de rte tout récent que 55 % de
l'énergie proviendra d'électricité
derrière le justement sur les
renouvelables on voit que la part de
l'éolien augmente de plus en plus
d'opposition se font jour dans les
territoires aux programmes et aux
projets d'éolien est-ce qu'il faut
mettre mettre un frein à ses à ces
programmes en tous les cas là aussi on
ne peut pas construire de l'éolien
contre les citoyens contre les aigus
voilà pourquoi nous avons regretté que
dans le texte climat résilience
l'association des maires aux décisions
ne soient pas réaffirmées commune pas
simplement une vague consultation mais
une conne et cision qu'ils soient prises
avec les élus il s'agit pas d'être pour
ou contre l'éolien il s'agit de trouver
aux énergies renouvelables leur place
dans le mix énergétique ce soit
consensuel
on ne peut pas les gens contre les
territoires alors autre sujet très
sensible gérard larcher qui est notre
invité ce matin sur ce plateau sur tv5
monde c'est la chasse philippe arnassan
de nice-matin rencontrer pour nous eric
de villars le militant pour la cause
animale du var d'ailleurs opposants à la
chasse il a une question à vous poser on
écoute
bonjour eric de villars référent one
voice pour le var
monsieur larcher le bien-être animal est
omniprésent dans le paysage politique de
notre société
les représentants politiques ainsi que
les citoyens français se sont emparés du
sujet et la chasse fait grandement
partie de cette thématique cette prise
de conscience correspond sans doute à
l'évolution de notre société et il
serait vraiment temps de légiférer sur
le sujet
comment vous positionnez vous monsieur
larcher par rapport à la grande majorité
des français qui refusent désormais la
chasse sur notre territoire merci
d'abord je suis chasseur vous attendiez
à cette question d'ailleurs oui je sais
pas mais je suis chasseur et en même
temps je suis un passionné de
biodiversité et vous savez les chasseurs
sont devenus aujourd'hui des acteurs de
la biodiversité est d'ailleurs au
travers de l'office français de la
biodiversité ça passe pas dans l'opinion
publique gérard larcher c'est une
réalité mais vous le savez j leblanc des
français ne veut pas que les plans dès
aujourd'hui au site de rambouillet si
c'était la fédération de chasse mais je
peux comprendre que mes cd ne
participent pas à cet héritage rural
aujourd'hui la question qui est posée
est qu est une question sérieuse c'est
la question de la biodiversité mais
aussi de la sécurité
est une question
qui ne peut pas être en quelque sorte
balayé d'un revers de main justin en
situation d'urgence sur la question de
la sécurité on a vu il ya de nombreux
accidents de chasse qui font de plus en
plus polémique quelle est la réponse est
ce qu'il faut comme le propose notamment
yannick jadot réguler en interdisant la
chasse le week end où certains à
certaines périodes il n'y a pas de plus
en plus d'occidentaux ils font de plus
en harley mik mais il y en a beaucoup
moins qu'avant mais un accident est un
accident mortel c'est toujours un
accident de trop il faut donc que nous
agissions sur les conditions d'exercice
sur la formation sur la responsabilité
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela répond
d'ailleurs à une pétition d
citoyenne que nous nous attachions sur
sur le site du sénat qui a dépassé les
cent mille signatures est-ce que vous
allez vous en saisir l'ensemble des
jeunes s'est dit avant même que le times
des sommes une signature parce que dans
notre règlement c'est par la première
édition dont nous saisissons la question
des adultes handicapés de la location
nous en ce moment et nous allons gérer
cela en responsabilité mais la chasse
fait partie de l'héritage de nos
traditions renan disait la nation est un
héritage en partage a bien à tous et
partage là si on apprenait j'allais dire
à partager la nature à se respecter les
uns les autres moi je respecte ceux qui
ne partagent pas mon héritage et est ma
passion je leur demande aussi de
respecter cet héritage de cette passion
qui fortement ancrée dans la ruralité la
une de nice matin denis carot
aujourd'hui la une de nice-matin
harcèlement que scolaire comment faire
face avec des solutions qui sont mises
en oeuvre le harcèlement scolaire ces
sept cent mille élèves qui sont
concernées chaque année merci denis
carot réfugiés qui errent a été partagé
ou à l'occasion des questions au
gouvernement
plusieurs rapports se penche là-dessus
je crois que c'est une responsabilité
collective dans lequel nous devons
soutenir les enseignants ceux qui
accompagnent permettre la prise de
parole par les familles parce que on
voit bien que ça peut conduire à des
drames absolue nous pensons tous à cette
jeune dit la merci denis carot rédacteur
en chef directeur des rédactions de
nice-matin du groupe nice-matin merci
dans un instant s'il vient gars à tv5
monde nous rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
si de garcia bonjour vous avez devant
vous le deuxième personnage de l'état
oui avec une question qui se pose parce
que c'est assez peu connu des français
s'il arrivait quelque chose au président
de la république vous prendriez les
rênes du pays le code nucléaire et
cédera comment ça se passe quel est le
protocole pot de colle il est inscrit
dans la constitution
j'espère qu'il n'arrivera jamais mais il
est arrivé deux fois pour un mes
prédécesseurs le président poher qui a
après la décision du général de gaulle
de démissionner eu pendant les deux mois
et il a eu à organiser d'élection
présidentielle et après le décès du
président pompidou en fait nous avons
une constitution qui prévoit ce que me
disait un de mes maîtres professeur de
droit le roi est mort vive le roi il ya
donc une continuité
de qui est voulu par notre constat
d'inquiétude pour les france elle est
connue claire se transmettre facilement
mais tout est réglé tout est prêt tout
est réglé en espérant que ça n'arrive
pas comme vous le disiez récemment l
affaire des sous marins australiens fait
grand bruit ce une affaire qui a des
conséquences pour la diplomatie pour
l'industrie pour le positionnement de la
france dans l'inde au pacifique pour le
cm sénat une commission denquête n'est
pas adapté pourquoi parce que c'est le
travail il a été ainsi décidé par la
commission c'est le travail de la
commission ce que je constate dans sept
ans ce dossier c'est qu'au fond la
parole de la france est affaiblie et
je le dis c'est pour moi une
préoccupation parce que la parole de la
france d'état tendu pour un certain
nombre de pays sur des valeurs que nous
portons et que la parole de la france
soit affaibli est réellement pour moi
une interrogation nous voyons bien que
sur le sujet indo pacifique nos amis
australiens néo zélandais américains ils
pourront pas faire sans la france y
compris parce que la france dans ce
nouveau monde qui retrouve les états
puissance
nous sommes un pays qui peut dialoguer
avec tout le monde puisse en saura le
recevrez sens moral ouais puissance
morale puissance aussi
de dialogue et puissance aux cibles
militaires
et nous sommes le seul pays je le
rappelle dans le cadre de l'union
européenne d'aujourd'hui à disposer de
l'armé nucléaire mais dans ses relations
diplomatiques
on évoquait à la crise ils sont marrants
serait bien ça a déclenché une crise
avec les etats-unis crise majeure avec
le manier avec l'australie avec la
grande-bretagne au royaume uni ça fait
beaucoup de crises en même temps dans le
monde traversé énormément de crise
regarder ce qui se passe à la frontière
polonaise aujourd'hui au travers de ces
a fui non pas migrants mais personnes
déplacées volontairement par le pouvoir
d'un dictateur le président biélorusse
situation aussi au moyen-orient
situation en afghanistan
nous faisions le point avec le chef
d'état major c'est en la présence de
groupes
paramilitaires
ou mali ou au sahel l'alésien plus ou
moins diligentée dans tous les cas
couverte par la fédération de russie la
présence de la france elle est
essentielle dans ces territoires dans
ces parties du monde elle porte un
message et nous sommes aussi ce qui
somme les plus engagés dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et contre
tout ce qui se passe en matière de
terrorisme et de tous les groupes
terroristes avec nos militaires
d'évoquer la biélorussie la commission
des affaires étrangères du sénat a
envoyé une délégation il ya un mois à
peu près ce que vous aviez vu les
prémices de ce qui a entraîné dur
maintenant le sanction parce que nos
amis en plus des états baltes et je les
avais rencontrés avec le président
cambon de la commission des affaires
étrangères nous avait fait part de leur
préoccupation de ce qu'ils observaient
nous avons je dois dire sur ce sujet
pardonnez-moi les frontières polonaise
ce sont nos frontières ce sont les
frontières de l'europe et sur le cash
and co a transformé un système d'état
dans un système aussi de traite des
êtres humains et savait que sa relève ça
relève la cour pénale est en finale oui
il n'adhère pas au statut de rome
j'allais dire ce pays mais c'est un vrai
sujet nous devons aider la pologne y
compris techniquement parce que c'est un
sujet essentiel si nous ils sont faire
exister la multiplication de la traite
des êtres humains parce qu'ils ont des
visas biélorusse et diane c'est
instrumentaliser la misère humaine parce
que ce sont aussi des hommes et des
femmes et qui sont des gens que nous
devons respecter justement la france
prend la présidence de l'union
européenne à partir de janvier le sénat
débattait des priorités quelles sont
elles c'était manière nous débattions
des priorités mais le gouvernement n'a
rien voulu dire de trop c'est puisque il
l'a dit il faut attendre que
l'expression du président de la
république le 1er décembre nous nous
avons des attentes et gagnent vraiment
extrêmement précises de la présidence
française de l'union européenne comment
on recouvre notre souveraineté sujet
post pandémie souveraineté au plan
européen souveraineté économique
souveraineté scientifique souveraineté
dans la production deuxième sujet
comment nous construisons sans
concurrence avec le tam comme un pilier
complémentaires une europe de la défense
et de la sécurité
troisième sujet la sphère biélorusse
tout le monde mais aussi les drames en
méditerranée en manche est ce qu'on peut
continuer à penser que chaque nuit il ya
des hommes et des femmes qui tentent de
quitter
et qui traversent la manche et quand
dont certains vont être noyé nous avons
des des cimetières il faut prêter la
question des migrations voilà trois
attentes vis-à-vis des criminels une
dernière chose ça concerne parce que
vous parlez des migrations de sécurité
ce sont les marottes de votre quand on
le voit à cette semaine devant le maroc
les réalités vous avez invité cette
semaine dans une interview les candidats
allaire à la primaire a l'air à aller un
peu sur d'autres terrains justement si
on les a menés sur le terrain de
l'internacional qu'est ce que vous
attendez comme proposition n'est pas
très d'accord vraiment de nos candidats
maintenant compte qu'on parle climat ont
par l'éducation qu'on parle aussi des
sujets euros bien qu'elle l'ait
puisqu'il faut que nous donnions une
vision de la place de la france en
europe et dans le monde et je souhaite
que les deux débats qui vont suivre
après des débats consacrés notamment la
sécurité
à la question migratoire un peu la santé
santé premier sujet de préoccupation des
français nous les abordons aussi bien si
c'est l'intérêt d'un débat démocratique
gérard larcher pourquoi vous n'avez pas
été candidat vous même puisque vous êtes
une des consciences des républicains
aujourd'hui pourquoi n'y a pas avoir été
au fond vous même non parce que je pense
que mon rôle c'est d'être président du
sénat oui mais j'ai reçu la confiance de
mes collègues je pense qu'il ya la place
pour une génération aujourd'hui nouvelle
réfléchi et qui mais vous savez à
l'image des cinq débats il nous montre
quoi une équipe de france
solide
qui a la capacité de gouverner ensemble
qui aujourd'hui alors qu'on les
attendait sur les divisions peuvent
avoir des différences messier légitime
toutes les qualités qu'on vous prêtez
d'ailleurs vouer mais alors je serai aux
côtés de celle ou celui qui sera choisi
le 4 décembre prochain est votre
préférence va varier pécresse des films
déclarations d'autres soit quand vous
l'avez deviné j'ai reçu ce milan là vous
étiez xi durable à sa candidature javier
bertrand j'ai reçu nous recevrons
philippe juin michel barnier dans mon
département méchant c'est que le
candidat des républicains tout gagné la
preview il réellement vraiment vous
pourriez gérard larcher s'il est présent
au deuxième tour y gagnera pour donc je
pense que nous pouvons gagner oui je le
dis devant les téléspectateurs du monde
que nous pouvons le faire à la condition
d'être unie rassemblée et d'avoir une
vision globale de ce que nous proposons
français n'ont pas nous engager dans un
catalogue de dépenses parce que nous
allons cet après-midi commencé un projet
de loi de finances avec une réalité
455 milliards de budget et encore on
sait pas si on va pas nous en rajouter
300 milliards de recettes déficit 155
milliards
il va falloir qu'on limite les promesses
c'est qu'on soit dans la réalité parce
qu'il va falloir retrouver la
compétitivité il va falloir retrouver un
équilibre financier et dire la vérité
aux français merci gérard larcher vous
êtes le président du sénat et vous étiez
notre invité sur tv5 monde aujourd'hui
avec nos partenaires de ouest france de
nice matin de france antilles merci
sylvia garcia et nous on se retrouve
jeudi prochain à la même heure c'est
françois hollande l'ancien président la
république qui sera notre invité les
programmes continus sur tv5 monde au
revoir à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]